Curren tonight we absolutely loved you
in Beauty and the Beast Emma Watson you
were the perfect pick for the
live-action movie we can't imagine
anyone else's Belle but we can't believe
you were offered the role of another
Disney Princess it's hard to picture you
as another famous Disney character but
you turned down the role we think it
worked out pretty well for you it's hard
to believe anyone who would turn down a
role in a Disney movie but these 10
actors definitely did
[Music]
keep watching to find out which famous
actress had to quit after getting hired
Leonardo DiCaprio Leonardo DiCaprio has
made a name for himself in Hollywood as
a serious method actor we don't do
anything illegal but early on in his
career he was offered the role of Max in
hocus-pocus can you imagine seeing Leo
in everyone's favorite Halloween movie
but Leo turned down the role he had also
auditioned for What's Eating Gilbert
Grape
and wanted to see if he got the part he
did and that was his big break he even
earned his first Oscar nomination
so obviously Leo made the right decision
Bill Murray
this Groundhog Day actor is a Hollywood
legend excuse me where's everybody going
and Disney loves getting legends to
voice their characters
Bill Murray had screen tested for
Monsters Inc and Pete docter
loves him for the role of Sully he was
the studio's first choice but when they
called to offer him the role bill
wouldn't pick up the phone they just
couldn't get ahold of him
so they took that to mean he didn't want
the part Jim Carrey there is no pirate
more iconic than Jack Sparrow from
Pirates of the Caribbean
[Music]
Johnny Depp has made the character at
Disney classic but did you know that Jim
Carrey was highly considered for the
role in fact for a while he was the top
choice this casting would have made the
movies totally different but Jim was
busy filming the hit comedy Bruce
Almighty at the same time Emma Watson we
can't imagine the better actress to play
Princess Belle than Emma Watson she has
so much in common with the Disney
Princess that Emma was actually offered
the role of another princess first
Disney wanted her to play Cinderella in
the live-action remake but Emma didn't
connect with the character so she
respectively declined the role later she
accepted the role in Beauty and the
Beast because she identified with Belle
inanimate objects if I'm lucky most of
the time that was nothing even on camera
with me and Hathaway this next entry is
a little different
Anne Hathaway still ended up starring in
the Disney movie but she accepted
another role Disney first offered an the
role of Alice
Tim Burton Alice in Wonderland movie but
Anne had already played an innocent
princess in The Princess Diaries she
thought Alice was too similar and didn't
want to create a pattern in her career
so she accepted the role of the white
queen instead Billy Crystal Billy
Crystal has a legendary fix our voice
he played Mike and Monsters Inc but he
was very nearly another iconic Pixar
character Billy was offered the part of
Buzz Lightyear in Toy Story it was early
on in the movie's development and Buzz
didn't have a name yet
Billy passed on the role and the part
went to Tim Allen instead the actor said
passing on that role is the only regret
he has in his career but still we can't
imagine Billy's voice as the heroic
Space Ranger keep watching to find out
which actors had to back out of a role
because she couldn't handle the voice
acting Selena Gomez for heading to the
small screen now Selena Gomez became
hugely popular on the Disney Channel in
Wizards of Waverly Place but the studio
also wanted her to star in camp Rock the
focus of that was music instead of
acting Selena knew that eventually she
wanted to be a musician but first she
wanted to build up her acting career
Michael Douglas Michael Douglas is a
Hollywood legend he's been famous for
decades so he didn't really need a
Disney movie to make him more successful
but he might regret not accepting a role
in frozen since it was the most
successful animated film for a while he
auditioned for the movie but he can't
remember what character he was supposed
to play he got the part and turned it
down Ryan Gosling America's heartthrob
was supposed to be in a live-action
Disney remake Ryan Gosling was offered
the part of beast in Beauty and the
Beast but he turned it down to star in
la-la-land instead it was a smart move
la-la-land won several Oscars the role
of the beast was offered to Dan Stevens
instead and a weird twist Emma Watson
turned down lala land to film Beauty and
the Beast maybe one day these two will
actually start together Reese
Witherspoon Reese Witherspoon actually
wanted this role but she couldn't handle
it she was originally set to play Merida
and brave but Reese could not get the
Scottish accent down she worked with
LuAnn with sick coach but she had
admitted that she was really terrible at
it she had to back down from the role so
that the Scottish princess would sound
well
Scottish the row ended up going to
Scottish actress Kelly Macdonald instead
I mean I I'm so pleased she is the first
female protagonist and I feel very
honored
do you love behind the scenes details
about famous actors and movies for more
fun videos subscribe to the things if
you're watching on your mobile open your
settings and turn on YouTube
unifications to never miss another video
which of these actors do you wish had
taken on the Disney role let us know in
the comments thanks for watching give us
a big thumbs up if you love all things
Disney see you next time on the things